the first signs of defiance since the
taliban took power in afghanistan are
emerging demonstrations have been
reported in several cities witnesses say
the taliban shot dead three protesters
in jalalabad who were waving the
national flag for the latest we can
speak now to journalists franz marty who
is standing by in kabul france we saw
images of protests yesterday in several
cities and violence what is the
situation today
the protests were apparently like quell
yesterday especially in jalalabad where
you have seen the gunfire i also talked
to people in hosts
where a similar protest has taken place
yesterday
there one source said two people were
killed
after hoisting the national flag
that said the taliban yesterday taliban
members have on social media now comes
that there will be a complete curfew in
horse
this seems to be at least partly
implemented now today in the morning uh
in the same tweets that taliban
announced also clearing operation host
apparently uh triggered by this protest
um to what extent this has actually
happened is hard to say two sources in
hosts said uh they either heard no
gunshots or only few
um they mentioned that the taliban did
patrols uh but i haven't seen any signs
uh of of a vast
clearing operation in reaction uh to
that protest
france i want to ask you about the
people who are still trying to leave the
country because we've seen reports that
the taliban are still blocking people
from reaching evacuation flights that
they are beating people away from the
airport and the u.s and allies are
trying to secure safe passage for these
people so what is the situation at the
airport
the situation at the airport is chaotic
there's also conflicting information so
i was told uh today in the morning the
gates to the airport are closed
um
this seems to uh have been a result of
both the
american side and uh the taliban side uh
being afraid that uh things get even
more out of control uh however there
have been people like reaching the gate
today so it's not a complete blocking of
the routes to the airport as far as i
can say
but for example i'm in direct contact
with an african-american citizen who was
told to come today in the morning
arrived and had no chance to get in as
the gates were apparently close and then
returned um so it is still chaotic uh
even people that are told to come can't
get in
what about the polit political situation
france we've been talking about the fact
that the taliban are saying they are not
the taliban of old and we did see senior
taliban figures meeting the ex-president
hamid karzai how inclusive could their
government be
this is remains to be seen however i
don't think chances are good for an
inclusive government
if one reads the taliban statements that
they have published
since last year were especially listens
to a speech that a high-ranking taliban
member gave briefly after the signing of
the u.s taliban agreement
there he said explicitly to government
officials lower ranking government
officials who repent
who acknowledge that what they did
during the past year was a mistake and
apologize for this
they are allowed to work in the
government under the taliban that's
apparently their idea of inclusiveness
so that they would really share power
significantly share power with other
factions is hard to see and frankly
speaking the way that they now took over
the country why should they um they see
themselves as victors um so they don't
need to share power with everyone
and all uh this talk about inclusivity
is probably at least in my assessment uh
will be rather superficial than an
actual significant power sharing
journalist france marty speaking to us
from kabul thank you
president joe biden has said the u.s
military might need to stay in kabul
past the august 31st withdrawal deadline
in an abc news interview biden rejected
criticism of the pull-out and said every
last american would be evacuated
while germany's government is also
evacuating people from afghanistan after
a slow start evacuations have picked up
speed around 900 people have now been
airlifted from kabul german military
aircraft are moving back and forth now
between kabul and the uzbek capital
tashkent to bring people out and from
there evacuees are being flown to
germany on commercial flights
and our reporter benjamin alvarez-gruber
is at frankfurt airport he's been
following the arrival of evacuees for us
benjamin can you tell us what things are
like where you are
good morning sumi the situation is now
calm here at the airport there are still
some family members and friends of the
evacuees waiting for them here when they
arrived in the early morning it took
quite a time because behind me you can
see the terminal where people and
families are coming out so it's a pretty
long process first we have the border
control by police then they have a covet
19 test and then some of them the afghan
refugees are handed over to the federal
ministry of migration and refugees
we arrived in the early morning the
plane landed from uzbekistan before 4 am
so pretty early similar to the plane
that arrived here yesterday more than
900 have been evacuated from kabul and
they will continue as well we spoke to a
woman who told us that her father 61
year old father had to wait for more
than 20 hours outside of the airport in
kabul to even make it inside so the
situation is still pretty dramatic for
them and we were also able
to talk to some of the people some of
the evacuees and who were on this flight
and this is what they told us
the world can't just leave and desert
the people of afghanistan
they're in a very bad situation and the
people need help
there is nothing cheaper than life
itself in afghanistan right now
the world is playing a horrible game
with us
the taliban have arrived in kabul a few
people have taken over it's a joke a
joke
harrowing testimonials that have one
thing in common on one side the relief
they made it out of afghanistan but on
the other side the uncertainty when it
comes to those who had to be left behind
all right benjamin alvarez gruber
reporting for us at frankfurt airport
this morning thank you very much
the u.n refugee agency has described the
human toll of hostilities in afghanistan
as immense it says that half of
afghanistan's population more than 18
million people are in need of
humanitarian assistance
conflict the coronavirus pandemic and
drought are behind the disaster issues
that have led to the displacement of
millions of afghans there have been
urgent calls by international
organizations and ngos to act decisively
to help those in need
well the crisis in afghanistan is
particularly hard on children amid the
chaos and violence scores of young
afghans are among the injured and killed
an estimated 75 thousand children have
had to flee their homes in the past
month and unicef says that millions of
minors suffer from malnutrition more
than half of them are under the age of
five
many of those children are at risk of
long-term health problems as a result
the number of children in need of
humanitarian aid is some 10 million
that's almost a quarter of afghanistan's
population
let's get some more perspective on the
story now we can speak to naheed
shahalimi she's an afghan-canadian human
rights activist filmmaker and artist and
she's based in munich here in germany
thank you very much for joining us you
spent the first years of your life and
your childhood in afghanistan tell us
first of all what goes through your mind
when you see the images that we see
coming from afghanistan
um thank you for having me here i don't
watch um this is actually the first time
that i watched in in two days because
we haven't slept in five days
um we're on the phone with our staff
because i have a lot of projects in
afghanistan that are running and there's
another one that's supposed to start in
about four weeks
um the the focus right now for me is a
solution oriented focus which means get
the people that we have fought for
the past 20 years to emancipate them to
empower them to democratize them um
you know the funding was was given by
the same by the same international
community that basically left them alone
there we have the moral obligation to
get these people out that is my focus at
this moment so um we have we're building
with um especially with the with the
tech community um uh i have just i'm
launching actually today in a few hours
the press release is gonna leave and
it's a campaign that is for solidarity
of afghanistan to have concrete
strategies on how we do it in which
phases as far as the taliban are
concerned we can everything that we're
talking about is
basic based on assumptions until we know
what kind of this inclusive um a
government that they're talking about
until we know the frameworks of which we
are allowed to work
we will never be able to assess or or or
even project anything or it's all
assumptions so for this moment this
campaign for me is extremely important
and the standard for unity campaign
existed before and now this part of it
is with nfts and the nfts in the tech
world that is standing by us through
creativity
we get these funds in cryptocurrency and
the decentralization part is extremely
important because of the fact that banks
are closed and all the assets of these
displaced people right are either frozen
that's that's what's gonna happen so
that's what i'm focusing on at this
moment
well you are helping people on the
ground you have many contacts there with
the projects as you said that you're uh
working on at the moment what are people
on the ground particularly afghan women
telling you about what they're
experiencing
um those that we are in touch with are
of course there's a lot of fear
uncertainty um everything that we are
are seeing this this this great behavior
that um taliban are showing uh is slowly
changing in action so as
the fear is completely there everybody
is afraid um a lot of them are in hiding
we are trying to make sure that that we
don't reveal the sources um and keep
them where they are so that we don't we
don't post and all of those things that
people do i just ask people
not to not to bring out posts that may
jeopardize the lives of these these
women especially these activists the
journalists the um the athletes the
artists all of these people that we are
working with a lot of their lives will
be engaged in danger so please do not
reveal
things that you're not supposed to
reveal just because you want to make a
post the best way is to put pressure on
the governments to take as many out as
possible especially those that are in um
you know in in danger of being
persecuted and they will be because they
have started we have reports that people
are looking for people we have reports
that that there are certain activists
that are being uh you know
after so these are these are real
reports
naheed could you ever see yourself
returning to afghanistan
yes
i will i will i will i do see myself
returning my
returning but with the help of the
international community so that we can
do those um those projects especially
the one that's coming up i i
conceptualized that for six years i've
been i've been working on this and it's
gotten through and the idea is to put it
in a framework which would be acceptable
for the taliban and it's an all-female
concept and and i'm hoping they i mean
we have been okayed
and it's supposed to go on i'm not gonna
reveal the name of the institution or am
i gonna say where it is however i do
hope that i i'd be able to go there in
the next couple of months because we
were supposed to go in 10 days
so
yes i do i do them absolutely because we
need we need to work with them
we'll have to leave it there
afghan canadian human rights activist
filmmaker artist thank you very much for
joining us here on dw